so today's game comes to us from Lukas
Berkowitz versus Alexander Shimon ah've
from 2013 and in this position Shimon
oov playing with the black pieces found
the winning move so go ahead and pause
your video and see if you can find it so
White's last move in this position was
Knight takes ecigs
so he gobbled up a pawn with the obvious
point that you can't play Queen takes
cuz there's a rook on e1 and if you take
with a pond you're just gonna be worse
because they take and you have some
weakness ISM this is okay that was his
tactical trick but as often happens when
you try to do a tactic sometimes it
backfires so if you haven't found it by
now so your last chance to pause because
here comes the solution what we do
notice one tactical possibility that
might occur is a pin along the e-file
and black actually has two major pieces
they could pin this knight and then
potentially win it however one is much
better than the other so hopefully you
can work out the differences the move
rook to e8 is actually not correct
because now white gets a big attack
after the move f5 for example if you
play Knight to f8 he's gonna get really
serious about attacking you when he
takes on h6 and now if you take the fish
up you're asking for a lot of trouble
and if you take the knight White has a
very strong move here f6 and this is no
fun for black at all he's in a lot of
danger here so we return
and in this position let's consider the
alternative which was played in the game
Queen to e8 and at first it might not be
obvious why lining these Queens up is
very important but it turns out it's
very significant the point is after f5
which was played in the game if you
proceed along the same line Knight to f8
suddenly the move Bishop to h6 which was
not played in the game runs into F takes
six and now because the Queen's are
opposed and your bishops under attack
white more or less has to take the Queen
and black his upper piece and in no
serious danger so in the game because
that didn't seem to work
he tried instead to move Queen to g4 but
black simply takes the knight and his
upper piece thank you everybody for
watching let me know in the comments
below if you were able to get that one
right hit like share subscribe and we'll
see you next week for another tactical
challenge